Michel de Nostradame, AKA Nostradamus
By Arnaldo Teodorani
Intro
[A slightly different intro here, with words
appearing on screen against a dark background,
as Simon read them]
From “Les Propheties”, Century nr XIII,
Quatraine nr LXXII
Anné dix-nouef la Terre est fatiguée
Un marteau de tenebre comme peste tombera
Des mains du Prince des mille fenetres, argentées
Puis seul et Roi des décombres, il rira,
l’homme qui siffle
I hope you did pardon my French.
My name is Simon, Simon Whistler [TA1] and
that was the quatraine number 72, from ‘Century’
- or chapter - nr 13 of The Prophecies, written
in 1555 by the most famous, most quoted and
most accurate visionary prophet of modern
times.
A French doctor, pharmacist, alchemist and
practitioner of the occult who in his lifetime
would advise Royalty and who after death would
never be out of print.
He is our protagonist of today: Michel De
Nostradame, better known as Nostradamus.
There
is little that we know with certainty about
his life and exploits, but we will trace his
career and look in detail at some of his most
famous prophecies.
And, as it is fitting for such a mysterious
character, there is more to be discovered
about Nostradamus and his prophecies, as proven
by the recent finding of a Century nr 13 in
the old library of his alma mater, the University
of Montpellier.
A chapter a pparently entirely dedicated to
the End of Times, from which we have quoted
the early quatrain … but more on this later.
For the moment, let’s dive into Nostradamus’
formative years.
Early Life
Michel de Nostradame was born in Saint-Remy-de-Provence,
southern France, either on the 14th or the
21st of December 1503 to parents Reyniere
de St-Remy, and her husband Jaume de Nostradame,
who worked as a grain dealer and notary.
Michel’s grandfather, Guy Gassonet, was
a Jewish doctor and Kabbalist who had converted
to Catholicism in 1455 and changed the family
name to Nostradame, as a means to avoid discrimination
and even persecution by the Inquisition.
We don’t know much about Michel’s childhood,
except that he was very bright and that he
advanced quickly through school.
Both of his grandfathers recognised his potential
for learning and dedicated themselves to tutoring
him.
His maternal grandfather, Jean de St Remy
taught him how to speak and read in Latin,
Greek, Hebrew, as well as the rudiments of
mathematics.
While his paternal grandad, Guy the Kabbalist,
introduced him to the more exoteric knowledge
of ancient Jewish tradition and the science
of astrology.
Although this has been disputed, it could
explain Nostradame’s interest in applying
the study of celestial bodies and how they
could influence human destiny.
Studies
At the precocious age of 14, Nostradame signed
up to the University of Avignon to study medicine.
His studies were cut short the following year,
however, because of an outbreak of the bubonic
plague.
This may have been his first encounter with
the deadly epidemic, to which he dedicated
most of his medical practice in later years
In the following four years young Michel travelled
the French countryside researching herbal
remedies and working as an apothecary.
In 1522, aged 19, he gave it another go at
getting a degree, this time entering the University
of Montpelier, at that time regarded as one
of the best for the teaching of medicine.
The faculty was largely composed of Catholic
priests, with whom he clashed often.
Apparently they were dismissive or even suspicious
of his early astrological knowledge.
Let’s not forget that this was a period
of great religious tension in the French Kingdom
with the Protestant faction of the Huguenots
growing in power both in the South and in
the Parisian court, causing the Catholic establishment
to be suspicious of any ‘heretic’ believer,
including those who had Jewish origins.
But what ultimately led to his expulsion from
medical school was a more mundane matter:
university officials found out about his previous
trade as an apothecary, something considered
as a lesser ‘manual trade’ and therefore
unworthy of that lofty temple of medical studies
that was Montpelier.
This approach is consistent with views of
the time, in fact even surgeons were considered
manual labourers and treated as “2nd class
citizens” by medical professionals.
But was he actually expelled, though?
After all, surgeons were allowed to attend
lectures in Montpelier, even though they had
to buy – or even steal - their own corpses
if they wanted to practice with their scalpels.[TA2]
And in fact, other accounts state that Michel
De Nostradame did complete his medical degree
in 1525, the same year in which he changed
his name to the Latin ‘Nostradamus’, as
was common practice among intellectuals and
academics of the time.
But did he actually get a degree, though?
Now, according to other accounts, it was during
the years 1521 to 1529 that we travelled the
countryside perfecting his herbal remedies
and apothecary skills.
In those years Nostradamus was aged 18 to
26 years old, the age in which one would normally
go to University.
As I mentioned earlier, there is little certainty
on Nostradamus’ earlier life.
But what it matters is that he did acquire
medical knowledge, either through study or
through hands-on practice, and that he would
use that knowledge against the bane of his
contemporaries, the bubonic plague.
The Plague Doctor
Over the end of the 1520s and early 1530s,
Nostradamus married and had two children.
He was frequently travelling, however, especially
around Southern France and Italy, treating
victims of the bubonic plague.
There was no known treatment at the time for
this infectious disease, but Nostradamus had
a stab at developing a healing powder:
‘Take one ounce of the sawdust of cypress-wood,
as green as you can find, six ounces of Florentine
violet-root, three ounces of cloves, three
drams of sweet calamus, and six drams of aloes-wood’
Did it work?
We know that violet-root is still used today
to treat cough and fevers, so maybe yes.
Although … calamus?
It is forbidden in the US because of its toxicity!
So maybe, not.
But: what Nostradamus did get right were the
methods to prevent outbreaks of plague: effective
personal hygiene, removal of infected corpses,
fresh air.
Simple stuff today, but pretty revolutionary
for XVI Century Europe.
Thanks to these measures Nostradamus became
a local celebrity in the Provence region,
in Southern France, even receiving financial
support from its citizens.
And in 1531, Jules-Cesar Scaliger, a leading
physician of his time, became his patron and
invited him to work with him in Agen, in southwestern
France.
But the plague did not rest.
Here is, in Nostradamus’ own words, a vivid
description of a common sight at that time
"Among the [most] admirable things I saw,
was a woman who, even while I was calling
to her through the window, replied to what
I was saying while sewing herself unaided
into her own shroud, starting with the feet."
She was later found dead in the middle of
the house - "with her sewing half-finished".
In 1534, Nostradamus’ own wife and children
died, presumably of the plague, while he was
on a medical mission in Italy.
In addition to being a personal tragedy, this
was a blow to his own reputation of plague
doctor, which caused him to fall out of favour
with both the community and his patron, Scaliger.
An Occult Awakening
In the years following the death of his family,
Nostradamus started to move away from medicine
and towards occult practices, most notably
astrology and divination.
According to legend – which unfortunately
is all we have – in 1538 he was forced to
leave France after a brush with the Inquisition.
During his travels in Italy he came across
a young Franciscan friar called Felice [Fell-ee-tche]
in front of whom he immediately knelt down.
Years later, the friar was to become Pope
Sixtus V. Nostradamus also journeyed across
Greece and Turkey, picking up more occult
knowledge and experiencing a psychic awakening.
In 1547, he returned to Provence, in the town
of Salon, and married a rich widow named Anne
Ponsarde.
The two would go on to have six children.
It was around this time that Nostradamus really
got into what he became most famous for: his
predictions.
He would bring upon himself a state of trance
by meditating for hours in front of a bowl
filled with water and herbs, or in front of
a mirror.
The trance would bring visions, and he would
interpret these into predictions.
In 1550, Nostradamus wrote down for the first
time these prophecies into an almanac, a popular
type of book at that time which included advice
for farmers and merchants for the coming year,
including astrological predictions.
The success of his almanacs, encouraged Nostradamus.
The year 1555 saw the publication of his magnum
opus, ‘Les Prophecies’, a collection of
predictions divided in Centuries, or chapters,
written in the style of four-verse poems,
known as quatrains.
These quatrains report Nostradamus’ visions
for the following 2000 years and are written
in a cryptic style using anagrams, metaphors
and an obscure combination of local French
dialects, Greek, Latin and Italian.
Some of his predictions famously anticipated
events such as the great fire of London, the
French Revolution, the advent of Napoleon,
the rise and fall of Hitler, and the 9/11
attacks.
Famous prophecies
Here is what Nostradamus wrote about the Fire
of London:
“The blood of the just will be lacking in
London,
Burnt up in the fire of '66:
The ancient Lady will topple from her high
place,
Many of the same sect will be killed.”
Besides clearly stating the fire of 1666 in
London, the doctor also gets another detail
right: ‘the blood of the just will be lacking’.
Not only the death toll of the fire was relatively
low with eight deaths, but the calamity had
also the positive effect of burning down millions
of infected rats, thus eliminating the outbreak
of plague that had ravaged the city in previous
years.
Now, for the French revolution:
“Songs, chants, and demands will come from
the enslaved
Held captive by the nobility in their prisons
At a later date, brainless idiots
Will take these as divine utterances."
This one is more open to interpretation, although
you find a reference to a rebellion against
nobility, a prison which could be the Bastille
stormed in 1789, and the rise to power of
brainless idiots – possibly the Directorate
during the Terror.
Napoleon also gets one:
"Pau, Nay, Loron, more fire than blood,
Swimming in praise, the great man hurries
to the confluence.
He will refuse entry to the magpies,
Pampon and Durrance will confine them.
"
The first three words are an anagram of Napaulon
Roy, which sounds like “Napoleon the King”,
who drew his power from military prowess – fire
– rather than aristocratic origins – blood.
There is also a vague reference to magpies
being confined, which has been interpreted
to represent Napoleon’s incarceration of
Popes Pius VI and VII.
Napoleon wasn’t the only autocratic conqueror
to be mentioned in the Propheties.
See what you make of this one:
“Beasts ferocious with hunger will cross
the rivers,
The greater part of the battlefield will be
against Hister.
Into a cage of iron will the great one be
drawn,
When the son of Germany obeys no law”
Hister does sound a lot like Hitler, plus
you have Germany in there.
And you even get a reference to ferocious
beasts – soldiers or even tanks?
– crossing rivers, in numerical superiority
on a battlefield.
The great one – being Hitler, again – will
be prisoner in a cage of iron, which could
be the bunker where he eventually committed
suicide.
And finally, Nostradamus’ vision of the
9/11 attacks:
“In the city of God there will be a great
thunder
Two brothers torn apart by Chaos while the
fortress endures
The great leader will succumb
The third big war will begin when the big
city is burning”
Two brothers torn apart: the Twin Towers.
The enduring fortress: the Pentagon, which
collapsed only partially.
And a ‘third big war’ – on Terror – to
begin straight after.
Could it be any clearer?
Celebrity Status
‘Les Propheties’ has not been out of print
since its first publication, but the book
that solidified Nostradamus’ celebrity status
was the
‘Traité des fardemens et confitures’
Or
‘Treaty on make-up and jams’
This is where he published the plague remedy
I mentioned earlier, as well as recipes for
candied orange peel and cherry preserve.
But the real treat is the ‘love jam’.
The ingredients for this concoction included
ingredients found in every larder nowadays
including cinnamon, cloves, wine, the blood
of seven male sparrows and the tentacles of
an octopus, preserved in honey.
But what was it for?
“If a man were to have a little of it in
his mouth, and while having it in his mouth
kissed a woman, or a woman him, and expelled
it with his saliva, putting some of it in
the other's mouth, it would suddenly cause
... a burning of her heart to perform the
love-act"
We at Biographics do not endorse this as a
method of wooing a lady, preferring to rely
only on our charm, wits and looks.
Nostradamus fame grew and he attracted the
attention of some VIP admirers, such as Queen
Caterina de Medici, wife to King Henri II
and real power behind the scenes of French
politics.
Nostradamus had hinted at some threats to
her family in his almanacs and so the Queen
summoned him to court appointing him Counselor
and Physician-in-Ordinary to the court.
In 1556, while serving in this capacity Nostradamus
clarified to her another prophecy from Centuries
I, which referred to King Henri.
‘Century 1 Quatrain 35
The young lion will overcome the older one,
On the field of combat in a single battle;
He will pierce his eyes through a golden cage,
Two wounds made one, then he dies a cruel
death.’
Despite being warned by Nostradamus to avoid
jousting matches, three years later, King
Henri then aged 41 years old, faced a younger
knight in such a duel.
His opponent’s lance pierced the king’s
visor – shaped as cage - and entered his
brain behind the eye.
After 10 agonizing days the King died of sepsis.
Death and Legacy
Nostradamus the doctor unfortunately did not
possess the knowledge to treat the ailment
which cursed him for much of his adult life:
gout.
The condition deteriorated into dropsy, which
is an excessive retention of fluids accumulating
in body cavities, causing heart failure in
its extreme form.
In late June of 1566, Nostradamus called for
his lawyer to draft his last will and testament,
to the benefit of his wife and children.
On the evening of July the 1st, he told his
secretary Jean de Chavigny,
“You will not find me alive at sunrise.”
Another accurate prophecy.
The morning after Chavigny found Nostradamus
lying dead next to his bed.
Nostradamus’ greatest legacy is, of course,
his prophetic body of work, which continue
to puzzle and fascinate scholars and enthusiasts
of the occult worldwide, striving to interpret
his more obscure writings.
We at Biographics want to play our part, too,
and so we will try to find the hidden meaning
behind the recently discovered quatrains which
foreshadow an apocalyptic future.
Remember the one I read at the beginning?
Here is our translation.
From “Les Propheties”, Century nr XIII,
Quatraine nr LXXII
[Script to be read in parallel to text appearing
on screen]
[Original French text appearing as subtitle]
‘In year 19 the Earth is tired’
Anné dix-nouef la Terre est fatiguée
‘A hammer of darkness shall fall like a
plague’
Is this a reference to the Spanish Flu epidemic
of 1919?
Or was he writing about 2019?
Un marteau de tenebre comme peste tombera
‘From the hands of the Prince of thousand
silver windows’
Silver windows may refer to mirrors, or screens.
A thousand screens – the internet?
Who is the Prince of screens who will cause
this disaster by wielding the hammer of darkness?
Des mains du Prince des mille fenetres, argentées
‘Later alone, and King among the rubble,
he will laugh’
The Prince becomes King, sole survivor among
the destruction.
But who?
Puis seul et Roi des décombres, il rira,
That’s him: l’homme qui siffle.
Which is French for
The Whistler
L’homme qui siffle
[screen fades to black, with or without ominous
whistling music]
[After two or three second the black screen
fades back to Simon]
Hello again, I hope you are still watching
and not too spooked by our little prank, here.
Let me reassure you that there are only 12
Centuries published in the Propheties and
no other quatrains were discovered in Montpelier.
I just wanted to make a point on how easily
in recent years the internet has fostered
unsubstantiated interpretations of Nostradamus’
predictions, or in some cases even circulated
quatrains that were completely made up![TA3]
Take the famous vision of the 9/11, which
I read earlier.
That prophecy was a total fake, made up by
a Canadian website to show how easily the
public can be fooled into believing such predictions.
Funnily enough, it was copy and pasted across
the Web and still believed to be genuine.
But the wild interpretation of Nostradamus’
writing style for sensationalistic effect
can be traced back to earlier years.
The famous “Hister” quatrain was popularised
by the book ‘The Prophecies of Nostradamus’
by Erika Cheetham, published in 1965, but
her translation from ancient French into English
is either genuinely inaccurate or manipulated
on purpose.
The word “Hister” in the XVI century referred
to the lower Danube region, not to a person.
The French original contains the word “Germain”,
which Cheetham translated as “German”.
But a more common meaning of the word in French
was “first cousin” or “brother”.
In fact here is another translation of the
same prediction by James Randi, the famous
Canadian stage magician and debunker of psychics[TA4]
:
“Beasts mad with hunger will swim across
rivers,
Most of the army will be against the Lower
Danube.
The great one shall be dragged in an iron
cage
When the child brother will observe nothing”
Which may refer to any number of engagements
during the Thirty Years’ War, or the siege
of Vienna by the Ottomans … but as you may
expect prophesising about WWII is far more
enticing.
To conclude, we don’t want you to doubt
all of Nostradamus’ work.
Sure, most of his predictions are vague, obscure,
impossible to decipher or open to exploitative
interpretations.
He may have just made everything up just to
sell books!
However, it is a fact that some of them contain
accurate depictions of what was then his future.